what do you think is happening and Tommy
I know you've gone back and forth and we
and but but I go back and forth because
when you lose morine out David Ignatius
liberal Joe when when you lose van Jones
and David aarod and James Carville and
Bill Mah now so and and when you get
tepid support from Nancy Pelosi and
James klyburn um now they're only going
after his age so far and they're not
very supportive of kamla either but to
me the dominoes are falling they don't
want him to be their candidate now if
they start reporting like this show is
and like you're both reporting about the
bribery moneya laundering allegations
then I think it's over for Joe will that
happen or if he falls again if operation
keep Joe from falling
fails assassination by gravity uh
probably the only president that that
could happen to um but I I do believe
that gavan the N she wasn't talking
about assassination she was talking
about him falling flat on his face
the Liberals out there to distort
everything we he say yes by his own
doing and we hope that that doesn't
happen we hope that he stays upright and
he does not fall we don't want anyone to
fall he nearly tripped on day one of
operation keep Joe standing straight
well he has new stairs but the Democrats
they can't keep lowering stair those
those are the baby stairs yes but they
can't they can't keep making them
shorter so at some point I think
Democrats are actually very excited
about the impeachment inquiry because
the Republicans are doing the dirty work
for them and are still grooming Gavin
Newsome you know it you talked to him
last night we're going to get to that
but they want Gavin Newsome they've got
to figure out a way to get rid of Joe
and comma kamla is more difficult as
I've said over and over again but Joe I
believe he's on his way out next thing
you ever see the commercial for the
chair that'll get you up the stairs I
think yes that's going to be all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else